taiwán fue el tema central del encuentro
virtual entre el presidente
estadounidense joe biden y su homólogo
chino xi jinping esto por la visita a la
isla de la presidenta de la cámara de
representantes de eeuu nancy pelosi
prevista para el mes que viene beijing
ha advertido sobre sanciones y pelussi
viaje a taiwán en su mundo incluso una
amenaza militar genio y fan de pero si
hemos declarado repetidamente nuestra
posición nos oponemos firmemente a la
visita de pelosi a taiwán si eeuu sigue
adelante y desafía a china
inevitablemente se enfrentará a firmes
contramedidas eeuu asumirá todas las
consecuencias dios y entidad y chejov
para beijing taiwán es una histórica
provincia de china aún no unificada con
el resto del país por ello rechaza
cualquier relación oficial en reta ewan
y otros países pero eeuu ya suministra
armas a taiwán y apoya su estatus
democrático combaten y reiterando en la
llamada que la postura de washington
sobre el asunto no ha cambiado
a taiwán el presidente de byd en subrayó
que la política de eeuu no ha cambiado y
que se opone firmemente a los esfuerzos
unilaterales para cambiar el statu quo o
socavar la paz y la estabilidad en el
estrecho de taiwán una disputa política
pero también económica la mayoría de la
cámara de representantes de eeuu
respaldó un proyecto de ley para
impulsar la producción nacional de
semiconductores con el objetivo de
responder a la escasez de los chips en
china- una medida que llevó beijing a
acusar a washington de sujetar su
relación comercial